how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to the channel we have
massive news today but before we get
started if for some reason you have not
seen spider-man far from home there are
going to be massive spoilers in this
video if you're still with me it seems
like Mysterio is not officially done and
out of the MCU now many people have
suspected that Mysterio didn't really
die at the end of far from home after
all he is the master of illusion so he
probably faked his own death this would
certainly explain how he could make and
edit a video pegging spider-man to be
the villain after he died and we know
that Sony is definitely planning on a
sinister six movie one that apparently
has plans for Mysterio to be a part of
it with a Spidey of course to be the
main antagonist of the sinister six so
let's talk about this awesome new report
today that says Mysterio could be coming
back possibly in his very own solo film
and how it could set up the sinister six
and the next spider-man crossover film
real quick if you're new be sure to
subscribe for a chance to win an Xbox
one or ps4 I'm picking a winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
so our report today comes from the
Illuminati com they've been pretty
active in the community lately you've
probably heard their name by now and
today the report goes as follows rumors
have already flown in the past that Sony
has plans for a sinister six film which
would include vulture Mysterio and
Craven while we cannot confirm the
validity of that particular source or
rumor it does line up with Keaton's
vulture appearing in the Morbius trailer
as well as the Illuminati zone
information that Craven will have MCU
connections our sources specifically
said that Sony wanted Jake Gyllenhaal
back for a solo film so according to the
Illuminati we could be getting a
mysterious solo film but what's
interesting is the way that we could
possibly get this solo film because
they've already kind of done an origin
story and spider-man far from home about
Mysterio he originally worked for Stark
Industries until he eventually turned
into a villain there's a little bit more
to that but that's basically the story
so it wouldn't make sense that they
would do sort of an origin story of
something that happened before
spider-man far from home so that means
it would have to take place after now
this would line up with Sony wanting a
sinister six movie this has been
reported many times and even Amy Pascal
an executive producer for Spider
and fire from home said that they have
everyone they need technically right now
that's been introduced in spider-man
films to do a sinister six movie so it's
definitely in the works
especially with Morbius coming out very
soon and with Michael Keaton's vulture
in the Morbius trailer and not to
mention that sign of spider-man that
says murderer on it so this really comes
down to the fact of did Mysterio truly
die at the end of far from home if this
report is true then the answer is no and
if you truly know who Mysterio is from
the comics this isn't that big of a
surprise he's the master of illusions
his death although it seemed very real
was just an illusion but what would a
solo Mysterio film have in store for us
it could take place after the events of
spider-man far from home it could
explore Mysterio trying to get revenge
on spider-man after all that is kind of
what he did with the film that JJJ
released but what now Mysterio already
hated stark and now he hates his prodigy
and if Mysterio went through all the
trouble of getting back at stark and
kind of the world he'll definitely go
through the trouble of getting back at
spider-man especially if he finds out
that other people aka the other sinister
six members are wanting to get back at
spider-man as well there really is a lot
that Mysterio solo film could be about
but it will most likely center around
the fact that he wants to get revenge at
spider-man and if Norman Osborn doesn't
enter the MCU anytime soon it could be
that Mysterio is the one to assemble at
the sinister six and there are plenty of
heroes that they could throw into a
Mysterio solo film as well and since it
would be a film focused on Mysterio they
most likely wouldn't use spider-man but
again there's just a whole slew of
characters that Marvel could use that
would be a perfect fit for the movie but
what do you think about this what do you
think the Mysterio solo film should be
about and which heroes do you think
should show up and try to fight him let
me know what you think in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe when notifications
turned on stay up to date on everything
relating to Marvel and so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or ps4 winner gets to choose at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
as always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff